une pelleteuse à quelques dizaines de
mètres du château du capitaine haddock
l'image est pour le moins inhabituel en
plein mois de mai a priori la marche à
toi combien normalement le feraient des
4,5
jerram cette équipe réalise une allée à
l'abri du soleil pour les touristes des
futurs files d'attentes
quand le site rouvrira même un des fils
du châtelain d'habitude en cours de
comptabilité à paris donne un petit coup
de main c'est différent de ce que
j'étudie en cours et ça me fait
apprendre d'autres choses dans d'autres
secteurs donc c'est vraiment
enrichissant
après deux mois sans recette
charles-antoine de vibrer a dû se
résoudre à l'évidence le château
rouvrira avec le virus alors autant
prendre des mesures dans un contexte de
crise les gens seront être discipliné
s'autodiscipliner pour qu'on limite les
temps de visite est de passage dans le
château à 30 35 minutes
si on savait qu'à partir de tout début
juillet on repartait sur une activité
quasiment normal on exploserait de
bonheur voilà même en ayant perdu sans
doute 30 à 40 % de notre chiffre
d'affaires à une centaine de kilomètres
de là l'édifice n'est plus classique
mais de style renaissance
ici dans les allées du château de
villandry les jardiniers s'affairent aux
abords de la pièce d'eau avec beaucoup
d'habileté
pourtant il n'ya aucun visiteur notre
travail il est un petit peu dans le vide
puisque personne peut le que le voir
donc si elles viendront on est habitué
ce qu on nous félicite de notre travail
à chaque fois ça s'est arrêté le
propriétaire a dû s'y résoudre lui aussi
il a fallu investir dans les cent mille
plants de fleurs d'été va probablement
réouvert dans un premier temps va
rouvrir dans un premier temps les
jardins qui sont très vastes et où on
est sûr de ne pas être les uns contre
les autres
puis dans un second temps l'intérieur du
château croyait derrière moi si la
reprise a lieu d'ici fin mai le pire
pourrait être évitée pour ses sites
visités par trois cent mille à 450 mille
personnes à défaut cheverny et villandry
continueront de pleurer leurs touristes